We were talking about how weird it was to meet Mike Tyson.
It's so strange to hang out and talk to them like party.
He was so iconic that whenever you're around them part there's like 10% of you
that has to go holy shit.
It's Mike Tyson.
No matter what else you're saying,
10% of your brain is going.
Holy Shit.
That's Mike Tyson.
When you showed the clip of the 51 year old Mike Tyson and hitting the bag,
I remember it as a child.
He was the first person I see.
I have two dads.
I have a non bio on the Bio Dad and I,
he was the first person I
say he hit with such vicious and evil intent.
It was amazing.
He could still do it.
Yeah.
That's what I saw him.
He was in the bag like he's still terrifying.
Yeah.
If he was a young contender coming up,
you would look at him and go,
wow,
this guy getting punch.
Yeah.
He doesn't have nearly the hand speed that he had when he was young.
Look at that man.
Yeah.
That was the peak.
He is an amazing story though,
man.
Listening to him describe his childhood and how custom motto had hypnotized him.
Yeah,
that was amazing because I'd never heard him talk about that before.
And that's what people need to understand.
Like who he was.
He people want to say,
oh he was,
he was hyper aggressive and he did terrible things and he was violent in this.
Think of how this kid grew up.
How's it forfeit?
Yes.
Literally or taken in by this one guy,
the first time in his life where anything is positive and it's all about
fighting and being a destroyer and he gets hypnotized by this guy to be a
destroyer and he's a physical specimen.
He really is.
You put your hand,
will you grab his?
Just his hand,
like his whole body is like carved out of a,
a large block of rock.
He's a tank of a man.
Wow.
You know,
still to this day he's a tank.
Absolutely.
And when he was young,
they saw that right away,
Teddy Alison on this podcast that when Mike was 13 weigh 290 pounds and they
didn't believe he was 13 they thought we were sandbagging.
They,
they put them in at 16 he said,
yeah,
okay,
say 16 nobody would believe he's 13 and they would come on,
you're shining these fucking kids to,
they didn't want to believe it and he just let him have it.
Okay,
okay.
You don't have it.
Because he said people were always lying about how many fights people had.
They would always say he's only had 10 fights and you see the guy move
immediately.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this guy's had 50 fights watching him,
and teddy was saying that that was always the hustle,
that everybody always lied a little bit about someone's record and when they saw
Mike Tyson,
it 13 when 190 pounds just dope fucking specimen is some people that are just
built perfect for certain things.
He was built to be this built perfect for bobbing and weaving and tight and he
was so fucking fast.
His Hook and uppercut.
I,
what's fighter has that upper cut?
Like the Lennox Lewis had a tremendous upper cut.
Eh,
there's,
there's some fighters today.
Joshua has a tremendous upper upper cut.
Yeah,
there's some,
there's some amazing talent today,
but it's like what Mike had done was revitalize the entire country's image of
the heavyweight division.
Yeah.
Cause [inaudible] for awhile and no disrespect,
but there was guys that just like pink when Thomas who's a champion and Tony
tubs,
they weren't the kind of guy that you like look forward to seeing as being the
champion of the world.
He didn't believe it.
Like I don't believe that's the toughest guy in the world.
It might be a tough guy.
I'm sure he's a tough guy.
He's a professional boxer,
but I don't think that's the best guy.
And then Tyson came along very is perfect name.
He had the perfect look.
He had the perfect body,
the perfect image and he came at the perfect time.
Yup.
When you look at hip hop and where it was and where Mike was at that time,
it was a perfect synergy for him to become a hero.
Mike Tyson.
Mike Jordan.
Like these people became icon is at a time where the United States,
like in the 80s after getting opaque kicking ass and the debt crisis fucking up
the 70s our ranch shit at the end of the seventies early eighties I steel armor,
my grandfather worked at hall steel,
remember steal my other grandfather steel leaving America.
I remember like it just kind of being like,
it wasn't as proud and he was one of those things that may you feel bad ass and
the Times feel dangerous and he wore black and those little boxes and you didn't
wear the boots.
He wasn't flashy.
Like he was a perfect villain at a time where Villainy Nwa,
you know what I'm saying?
It was was celebrated danger.
I think he was perfect for the time and I think he's perfectly now like what
Mike is when I hear him interview and I really talk and people make fun of his
list,
but whatever,
and I think that gets a new way of you hearing a real wisdom.
He saying a lot of times it's like Mike is repeatedly talked about change and
about growth and about how he doesn't see things the same.
And I think if we actually listened to that,
it kind of challenged us to do the same shit that we really don't want to do.
Yeah.
He's a,
one of the rare guys that you'll talk to that accomplished an insane amount,
literally became one of the most famous boxers in the history of the sport.
And you talk about him now and all he wants to do is dismiss that past life.
He went to,
he like,
I was,
uh,
I was silly.
Look,
uh,
look at me.
I'm a silly person.
Like,
he's a real warrior.
Like he's,
he's,
he is like in a classic come fulfilled.
He's the reluctant teacher almost.
You know,
he's,
you know,
you do,
you,
you know,
you do a,
you do a movie.
Mike is the guy who used a student go to beg to teach you to fight and you've
won.
You want to know why he won't teach you in this because you find out later your
teacher killed someone you know in the ring or some shit like he is.
He is really that character.
He is a,
he's,
you can tell even with the pigeons back in the days that there's kindness and
love in there somewhere.
Yeah.
And now he gets to express it to human beings.
You just see he's a happier person.
You know what I mean?
Until you bring up don king's name.
Yeah.
Don't do that.
And then,
then you get scared.
Like he's going to fucking beat me up.
And my dad too.
He,
the crazy thing about him selling weed now is that he,
they charge,
what did they charge him?
$300,000 I think for,
he tested positive for the Andrew Gelada fight for weed.
So they find him $300,000.
They just stole money from him cause he had weed in his system.
Wow.
Now he sells weed.
When did I go on my NFL guys?
They should let everybody smoke it.
It's good for your brain if you're,
if you're,
especially if you're doing something like slamming into each other,
running 30 miles an hour.
Yeah.
It's probably good to give them something to calm them down.